roll up roll up come one and all
the circus is in town and not just
any circus the greatest show in
all the multiverse don't pay attention
to the fact that the tents weren't here
yesterday
or that you don't remember hearing
anything about it before now
that's just the circus magic at work and
there's no
circus more magical or more mysterious
than herman fuller's circus of the
disquieting
it's a show so marvelous that even the
scp foundation
wants to get in on the act so come watch
the show come feel the magic
after all what do you have to lose
the story of this humbling traveling
show begins in 1893
with the founder herman s fuller he was
born into a wealthy family and at the
age of 21
he was invited by his uncle to chicago
to see the buildings his company had
constructed for the world's fair
he was dazzled by the sights he saw in
the windy city
and from then on he dedicated his life
to finding a way to bring that same r to
people across
america and eventually the world
after receiving a small loan from his
uncle herman fuller set about building
the miraculous circus you see before you
today
he knew he had to get a leg up over his
competitors after all the 1890s were a
golden age for traveling shows in
america
so herman devoted his time to research
trying to find acts and oddities that
were truly
out of this world he learned the way
between worlds
stole books from the wanderers library
and with them studied alchemy
transmutation sarcasm and other
supernatural
disciplines that real magic and touch of
the macabre would be what made herman
fuller's circus of the disquieting
so special and would ultimately give it
its longevity
herman fuller's first anomalous
acquisition was a genuine fiji mermaid
like the one that famed showman pt
barnum kept on display around the same
time period
unlike barnum's however fuller's mermaid
had been brought to
life the crowds loved it but like all
attractions pretty soon crowds grew
bored of it
and hungered for the next strange sight
so fuller went about acquiring more
curiosities his next important
acquisition was the man with the upside
down
face or manny for short he serves as
second in command to the ringmaster
and manages things behind the scenes
including the
acquisition of new talent many other
anomalous beings and items were
purchased for the circus by fuller
through the auction company known as
marshall cutter and dark
another group that the scp foundation
makes a habit of keeping tabs on
another thing that sets this circus
apart from any others
is the clowns because they aren't like
any
you've seen before though herman
fuller's circus of the disquieting
employs professional clowns
the vast majority of the clown troop are
non-human descendants of an
extra-dimensional race of magical
shape-shifters nobody really knows why
they decided to come to our reality and
help herman fuller set up his circus
but the leading theory is simply that
they were bored
these original clowns are the
progenitors of the turn clowns and the
bread clowns
turned clowns being humans who underwent
a clown transformation procedure
and the bread clowns being artificially
grown children produced by the other two
types
earlier in the circus's history before
we knew what we know today about
genetics
much more barbaric methods were used to
create new clowns
young human subjects would be subjected
to beatings and painful transfigurations
at the hands of the
child breaker these days however the
circus no longer employs a child breaker
instead the creation of new clowns is
the responsibility of resident clown
breeder
richard c normus and before you say
anything don't laugh
that is his real name some of the most
famous clowns in the troupe are eugene
and pius
both of which are original clowns mr
noodles who is a bread clown
and icky the troop leader who was once a
human with magical
abilities known as veronica mason she
still possesses her anomalous powers as
icky
and her magic act is one of the most
beloved parts of
our show after the sudden disappearance
of herman fuller
icky inherited his position as
ringmaster
and has been doing a spectacular job
ever since
not every attempt to create new clowns
has been successful as icky and mr
noodles though
some of the earlier attempts were quite
grotesque to look at
hermanfuller's troop of clowns are an
enthusiastic happy-go-lucky but
occasionally violent bunch capable of
minor feats of reality bending that
allow them to perform
all manner of tricks they live on a diet
of mostly sugar
and need to be milked regularly clown
milk is an invaluable substance here at
the circus as it's the secret ingredient
of the famous black cotton candy
which by the way is free with admission
it causes the brain
to produce high levels of serotonin
meaning that when you eat it
you're primed to have a great time be
careful though
raw concentrated clown milk is not for
human consumption
though the clowns love to drink it even
a small amount can cause a human to go
into cardiac arrest due to an overload
of happiness the sound of calliope music
also goes a long way to helping people
truly get the most out of their visit to
herman follow circus of the disquieting
the calliope is self-playing and
requires rolls of perforated paper to be
loaded into it so that it can play a
variety of pre-programmed pieces of
music
each piece produces a different
psychological effect on visitors who
have consumed their cotton candy
the skater's waltz will make them accept
whatever they see at the circus
no matter how weird as nothing out of
the ordinary
wonderful for making sure nobody blabs
about their experience to a certain
pesky foundation officer of the year
makes them less likely to perceive an
event as unlawful
we use that one when we suspect the cops
are closing in
hell hell the gang's all here is used to
get people to congregate at the big top
for showtime
and american patrol causes those who
have eaten their cotton candy to seek
out those who haven't
in order to strongly encourage them to
have some
what do you mean you lost your dog is
one that gets played after hours when
it's time to get the clowns ready for
milking
now that you have an idea of the history
and how things work around the circus
it's time for the tour the circus is
made up of a series of tents and
trailers
as well as a midway with standard rides
and games that you might find at
any circus outside the big top where
shows are performed once a day
there's also the den of freaks and the
hull of humans extraordinaire
the den of freaks is home to fantastic
acts like slugo
and eliza the living head sluggo is a
man whose eyes are on stalks like those
of a slug and he can bend those stalks
into any shape he wishes
he can even use them to create the
shapes of human faces
eliza the living head is a woman whose
head lives independently of her body
which is safely kept in storage even
without her body she can speak and sing
and often answers questions from the
audience
the hall of humans extraordinaire is
home to performers who lack physical
anomalies but otherwise display
otherworldly talents like the amazing
zoltan
a fortune teller and alchemist who
fuller picked up at a place called the
utterly bazaar
the hall of humans extraordinaire also
used to be home to
icky the clown back when she was still
veronica the magician
the recent lineup has changed quite a
bit thanks mainly to the activities of
the circus's constant
enemy you guessed it the scp foundation
or as they are better known to the
stable of interdimensional clowns
as the miss scp foundation
the foundation does not appear to be a
fan of circus folk and many of the
former acts are now
in their containment for example madame
rezarta and her amazing palm reader
also known as scp-1884-a
and scp-1884-b
was a blind albanian woman in her 60s
who was born without hands
she shared a psychic link with a
creature named luana
who was a large shapeless entity made up
of 932
hands hundred twenty nine of these hands
appear to be those of an
old woman and share madame rezarta's dna
but the remaining three hands seem to be
from a male caucasian adolescent
an adult hispanic female and a bengal
tiger
through her psychic link luana acted as
madame reserta's eyes
feeling its surroundings to provide her
with a mental map
fuller attempted to buy the two of them
when they were eight years old
but when their parents refused he sent
manny to whisk them away
under the cover of darkness maram
reserta's act involved sending luana to
feel the faces of audience members
and then trying to describe their
appearance based on what
luana felt the act was a hit but
maram rosarta claimed to have been
horribly abused during her time with
herman fuller
the two of them escaped while on tour
and were picked up by old scp
while trying to rent a hotel room in the
uae
then this virtuoso also known as
scp-1860
virtuoso was once a book of sheet music
that was transfigured by herman fuller
into one of the circus's
original acts it's a tall thin humanoid
being
encased in a densely woven paper-based
material
that stretches like nylon or spandex it
constantly drips black ink
ink which it has a telekinetic control
over
it uses the ink to create the shapes of
musical notes which float around it
while it
sings virtuoso can sing in multiple
voices at once across
different vocal ranges and constantly
performs
arias and show tunes for whoever is
listening
it was recovered from underneath a burnt
down shack at a fairground where the
circus had been set up
earlier in containment virtuoso still
sings
but translations from italian reveal
that the lyrics of the arya's at singing
have been
changed to reflect its own situation
some of these translated lyrics include
one day i'll tell you of my
creation and life within the circus born
from the ringmaster
his breed another act the circus dearly
misses is motormouth
also known as scp-2094 he was one of the
rare human clowns born in new york city
in the late
70s from birth he displayed a
supernatural level of flexibility in his
lower jaw
and as he grew older he discovered that
he could swallow large objects
and store them in a kind of pocket
dimension until he needed them
again unlike madame rosarta he went with
manny willingly
as even at eight years old he knew that
his alcoholic mother didn't care if he
lived or died
motormouth took to the circus like a
fish to water and grew from a shy
child into a very talented talkative and
highly charismatic adult
he was a juggler first and foremost who
would catch pins
balls and knives in his mouth as part of
his routine
but the name motormouth came later in
his career when he let a stunt driver
drive a car
off a ramp and down his throat however
as great an act he was
a conflict arose between him and manny
over manny's questionable methods of
sourcing new
acts many found out that motormouth had
been helping some of the anomalous kids
that manny brought in to get
back to their families and as punishment
for his insubordination he was locked in
a box
and left behind at the end of a japanese
tour
the box was marked for essie because
many thought being put in containment
was the best punishment
he could think of with how strange and
unusual
its acts are and how it always seems to
pop in and out of new locations at
strange
and unpredictable times you might wonder
if the circus has
any sinister motives well the truth is
though sometimes the acts can be a
little
gruesome their methods of acquiring new
talent are a little
unorthodox and the clown's a little out
of control
their only goal is to entertain
in that respect they're no better or
worse than any other circus
so we hope you've enjoyed your visit
make sure to stick around for the show
and don't forget to take your
complimentary serving of cotton candy
because there's nothing quite like a day
at the circus
especially one like herman fuller's
now check out scp chaos insurgency
explained
and secret group that runs the world
scp-05 council explained
for more mysterious groups from the
world of the
miss scp foundation